wake up taking over your life right now
I've got Gary Vee with me
[Music]
you got your prospective happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
you want to help people while you
scratch your itch for what you want to
it's an important thing I think you'll
get caught I highly recommend even
considering your circumstance
my biggest Gary mentor piece of advice
you can help people without making money
oh yeah so I think it's super important
like is little bit I get it but you
understand the ambition too
there's a lot of ways to help people
without like getting logos on your
everything and getting $15,000 of speech
and it's an important point I'll tell
you why it is the most important
differentiator it's awesome and my
favorite part about you is your
entrepreneurial ambition it's so you can
you can aspire to fulfill yourself and
give back so much you can be a [ __ ]
ninja entrepreneur [ __ ] hardcore
capitalist and build [ __ ] the [ __ ]
biggest business in the world and you
could be an awesome person I wish we
could get everybody to win for yourself
and help others win too there's
abundance out there you can win and they
can win too and there's people that over
you know talk about like I'm gonna give
and there's some other people who are
like I'm gonna win it's just like all
convoluted it's both it's [ __ ] boat
[Music]
say and I guess my question I do social
media marketing I mean I use obviously
nothing compared to what you do but I
noticed that it's like a system you have
to have to get where you want to get
okay so it's just creating that system
is the process it seems like like
remarkably individual right bro there's
no process there's your process you need
to figure out you and if you're the kind
of person that needs eleven hours of
sleep because that's your DNA
then get your eleven hours of sleep and
dominate the other thirteen if you're
the kind that needs an hour for
breakfast lunch and dinner and watch
YouTube videos of like [ __ ] people
climbing trees and like that's how you
roll then enjoy your three hours of
watching people climb trees during your
food consumption hours and do you like I
hate that people try to be like me
I have ridiculous over-the-top natural
energy that makes no sense to me and
anybody else that knows anything about
me so like don't wish on yourself just
figure out who the [ __ ] you are and do
[Music]
today my only goal is to inspire you to
take on your day go to bed feeling
amazing
wake up taking over your life right now
I've got garyvee with me with my butt up
to me up there with the top dogs of
inspiration motivating whether you want
to start a business whether you just
want to feel better about yourself gary
is the man I know you guys always say
that I lift you up but I brought in a
little extra support that's all you
think we're doing right now for however
long this video is is our goal our only
challenge is to lift them up I think
there's two core things I think about
when I think about people feeling like
they're at their lowest at a young age
number one somehow you have to and maybe
it's this video or maybe it's something
else realize you haven't even started
living perspective of age is imperative
you know if you're 10 knowing that
you're gonna live for another hundred
years for a lot of logical brings
they're like oh my god wait a minute I
have just started and even if the next
10 years are not great I still have my
entire life right number two and this is
the big one
gratitude I think one of the ways a lot
of people like Gary how are you help so
many people get at a low point I'm like
by having them focus on what's amazing
you know I sit on the board of a charity
water when I really figured out that
there are tons millions of people in
Africa walking 7 miles for water for
this literally here it is for water you
start putting things in perspective I
just genuinely believe that if you're
even capable of watching this vlog
you're already in a very special place
the likelihood the odds of being born is
400 trillion to 1 400 you are more
likely to win the lottery seven times in
your life than actually being born
I want gratitude to become a pillar of
conversation in our society because you
have to be grateful you have to be
grateful for what you have instead of
worrying about what you don't have for
every car from
money for fame for jewelry for
everything you don't have you have so
much and my great-grandma Anya taught me
a long time ago if you've got health
you've got wealth and every day I'm so
grateful that the eleven people I love
the most were awake and born that day
I'm alive and not sick and not
terminally ill and didn't die and then
so every business problem every skinned
knee becomes so small because I'm just
so grateful for the thing that actually
matters if and here's the analogy you
know when you're driving and the like
police lights go on and you're think
you're about to get pulled over and then
the cop drives past you and you get so
relieved and then for five minutes
you've got both hands on the steering
wheel right like you've got both you
steer it you've got both hands on the
steering wheel and all of a sudden
you're like driving the exact speed
limit and then like 15 minutes later
again you're going 15 over and you're
one-handed that's how I think about this
you have to stay grateful you can't take
things for granted we have so much
abundance in the world
so much opportunity and too many people
are crying about what they don't have
instead of being so deeply grateful for
what they have I'm so glad we did that
it's awesome I'll reach out anytime
honest is incredible do it anytime
you're in New York and you need
somewhere to crash to work for a few
minutes in between or anything we can do
I mean it's crazy
take care of yourself in Smith I would
say keep it up but I already know you
will you Willis want me to take care
[Music]